From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Tuesday 7 June 2011. My name is Joe Mosnier of the Seven World History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with videographer John Bishop and we are in Columbia, South Carolina at Matthew J. Perry Jr. US Courthouse, Judge Matthew J. Perry Jr.
We are here to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Judge Perry is a great honor and privilege to be with you this morning. I know you have a busy trial schedule today. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you for taking time here this morning and we will honor your calendar and the need to be fairly prompt and quick in our process here.
Let me ask you to start today if I could. We have just a description of the circumstances in the late 40s, 1948 when you entered law school and the context for the new law school
and what you encountered in that new recently created law school.
Well, if I might take you back before the beginning of the law school. You may know or if not I'll tell you that I am a veteran of World War II.
I was born and read here in Columbia. I was born in 1921 and I was a student at South Carolina State College when the Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor.
A national draft occurred and I was of course a young person who fit within the age brackets and I received my draft notice.
I reported for duty, well the notice came in December of late November of 1942 and I reported for duty near the first of January 1943.
I served in a segregated Army outfit, a Quartermaster Corps. We did our basic training at Camp Van Dorn, Mississippi and traveled and did our maneuvers in that area of the country.
I mentioned this because you may know that having been born and reared in the deep south, I was subjected to and was very accustomed as a young man growing up to the requirements of racial segregation.
It was widely practiced, there was no question but what we were subjected to the constraints imposed upon us as a people through the law.
Now I mentioned that because you see having grown up and having been accustomed to it, why initially as a child I'm not sure that I fully appreciated it all, the injustice of it, that anything was wrong with it.
But as I grew and as I developed and as my horizon is expanded, as I grew intellectually, I did begin to wonder about the justification for much of what I experienced.
If you have seen and read a book that describes my activities in South Carolina, you will note that they make reference to an experience I had when I was in the armed services.
I think it was a weekend pass at the end of my basic training and was traveling home to Columbia South Carolina by train.
I was before air travel had come into existence or if so I knew nothing about it.
We had a training on the train, of course, we had to sit in passenger cars reserved for members of our own race.
There were just widespread practices everywhere including at restaurants and other activities. All right, the train we had to change trains in Alabama in Birmingham, Alabama.
And of course my weight there for my connecting train was something more than two hours by the way it was rather inclement weather, damp and everything.
And I was hungry. Now they had a terminal restaurant and I couldn't go in the restaurant.
That didn't bother me because you see I had never been permitted to go into a restaurant that was reserved for white citizens. On the other hand, remember now I'm now a young person who is in the midst of growth and demand hood.
And instead I had to go to a window outside the kitchen or adjacent to the kitchen to order my sandwich through the window, other black soldiers and other black passengers were doing the same thing, had to stand on the line and wait my turn.
Now looking through into the restaurant, by the way our nation was already engaged in war with the Italians.
And there were some Italian POWs and who were being brought and transported into the United States to be housed in prisoner of war camps as I later understood.
But here were a contingent of Italian prisoners of war. They were dressed of course in their uniforms and surely our own military police were stationed around but they were in the restaurant.
And they were being served and the young waitresses were treating them with courtesy and one got the impression that some of them found the young men very attractive, quite understandable reaction on their part.
But as I looked and as I contemplated here I was at that time an American soldier. I was wearing the uniform of my country. I had just gone through basic training. I had been trained to go into a matter involving our engagement with the enemy.
Of course I had developed a sense of pride in my status as an American soldier. But here I was denied a privilege.
Once again it was not strange to me but now a certain feeling of insult began to develop within me. The injustice of it all I think became more clear and I wondered about it justification.
I wondered what if anything could be done about it. I had not been trained in the law and so therefore I hadn't come upon any solutions in my own mind.
I mention that to you because that experience remains with me. And so as I continued by the way we served in England, France, Belgium, Germany and we traveled around the world.
After the war I was discharged in January of 1946 and I returned to my native Columbia South Carolina.
Now I needed to complete my undergraduate college training. So I had decided that I was going to return to my alma mater South Carolina State College.
I had to return in the fall at the beginning September. But during the spring months there came to trial two cases in the federal courts here in Columbia.
And a couple of friends and I also veterans of World War II learned about the fact that these cases were about to be tried that we're getting a great amount of publicity.
So we decided to come up town to the court, not this building of course. The building is now the home of the US Bankruptcy Court (current); previously US District Court for SC around there on Laurel Street near Laurel in assembly.
And that's where US Bankruptcy Court (current); previously US District Court for SC was. And so I went in and I and others were spectators and we saw these two cases, tried back to back.
One of them was the case of a black citizen named George Elmore who had brought a suit on behalf of himself and others similarly situated against the election officials of South Carolina.
Challenging the fact that he and others similarly situated meaning black Americans were denied the right to vote in white primaries.
The Democratic Party of South Carolina and the Democratic Party and other states around the certainly around the deep South operated what were known as white primaries.
And Mr. Elmore and others were challenging this by the way the United States Supreme Court had already decided a couple of years before that in a famous case called Smith v. Allwright that practice as practiced in Texas was unlawful that it was a denial of equal protection.
And so that was the precedent that I did not then know about Smith v. Allwright but I've later learned about its significance but that was the basis upon which the case was fought in the district court here in South Carolina.
The attorneys in that case headed by Thurgood Marshall.
I had never seen or heard of Thurgood Marshall before that time.
Also Robert L. Carter was there.
Robert L. Carter was then a young associate of Thurgood Marshall's, who was either then or later became the chief assistant to Thurgood Marshall.
The local attorneys were Harold Boulware, a lawyer here in Columbia.
There were other lawyers who were listed on the brief Fred Robinson and I understand that a Mr. Parker who was not president in the courtroom his name was on the brief.
I believe that Mr. Morgan of Orangeburg who was popularly known as Squire" Morgan that was not his real first name short for Esquire.
In any event I witnessed the trial of that case and they tried it and of course the judge took it under advisement later decided of course in favor of Mr. Elmore and others.
But then upon the conclusion of that case the other case was tried.
That was the case of a young black American named John Wrighten who had applied for entry as a student in the law school at the University of South Carolina.
And Mr. John H. Wrighten III also represented by Thurgood Marshall and others was suing for the right to enter the University of South Carolina's law school.
Again I was aware that I and other blacks could not attend the University of South Carolina.
We had a black school.
There were other black schools here, Benedict College and Allen University and Claflin.
But South Carolina State College was the only state supported institution.
By the way that was not its correct name in the statute.
The statutes defined it or named it the colored normal agricultural and mechanical college at Orangeburg.
A name that we found distasteful.
And of course popularly we began calling the school South Carolina State College.
We're back after a very short break.
All right.
I witnessed the trial of that case completely.
And I was certainly impressed by the performance of these very fine lawyers.
And remember now I'm as a young person I'm in the stage of developing into manhood, developing intellectually and chronologically.
And so I had naturally begun to contemplate what my life's work might be.
I had already started my undergraduate training.
I was about to return to complete my undergraduate college work.
And I had begun thinking about what will I turn to?
Will it be in the business world?
Will it be in other professional callings?
How about medicine?
I decided against that.
But the business of wondering about how society might justify the racial practices that I had become increasingly aware of, weighed with me.
Could I enter some field or study some field that might better equip me to understand what I was looking at, to understand the reasoning for it, and to perhaps, along with others, try to find some solutions to them.
And I think that these were the considerations that prompted me to turn and to decide upon the study of law.
Now, where will I pursue my training?
I had, of course, privately decided in my mind that, well, I'll go to Howard University.
That was the school that I had heard about, and I knew I learned that the lawyers that I admired so much had gone there.
And so I had made that decision.
All right.
Judge J. Waties Waring, who had presided over both of these trials, made his decisions in both instances.
He decided in favor of Mr. Elmore and others in the voting rights case.
He decided in favor of the plaintiff in Wrighten v. South Carolina.
In that case, he decided that South Carolina had to either admit John Wrighten and others similarly situated to the school of law at the University of South Carolina, or provide for him and others similarly situated.
A separate but substantially equal education and some other institution or cease to offer a legal education at all.
So those were the three-fold judgments. Well, South Carolina decided to open the very inadequate school at South Carolina State College.
I say the very inadequate. I didn't know then that it was, well, I did know then that it was certainly not the equal of the law school at South Carolina.
I didn't know much about any other law school. And so I didn't know what to compare it to.
But history, of course, will support my assertion that it was not an equal facility.
In fact, Thurgood Marshall referred to it as a Jim Crow dump.
All right. Well, they began their hired a law school dean and they began hiring teachers who came to the campus while I am in the process of completing my undergraduate studies.
Now, these the law school people needed students. And of course, I guess the word had gone around that there's a veteran down there, a young fellow named Perry, who claims he's going to study law. Why don't you see him?
So one such person came to me and I responded, well, no, but I'm going to go to Harvard. I'm, yeah, I'm going to study law.
So this fellow said, well, I can understand and appreciate that. Why don't you come in and sit in and listen to it some of what will be going on.
And you better understand what you're going to be exposed to when you get to Howard." I was, of course, I had only part-time courses.
So I did have time to go and monitor and sit in. And so that's how I became involved in the study.
I ended up remaining at that institution. And there weren't many of us. We studied hard. We had teachers who had been well-trained.
The dean was then a graduate of Harvard University's law school. There were others who had graduated from other very fine institutions, Columbia University, University of Kansas, University of Iowa.
And several others. And of course, they instilled within us a concept of hard work we had to develop. We had to study.
Just five in your class.
In the graduating class of 1951, the first class had only two graduates. That was the class of 50. Now, interestingly, this first class, you see, at the time, and up until this time, South Carolina had a practice by which,
well, it was known as the diploma privilege. If you had graduated from a law school in South Carolina, you didn't have to take the state bar examination. You were admitted under what became popularly known as the diploma privilege.
Now, when the law school at South Carolina State was created, the officials decided, well, look, we've got to do something about this diploma privilege.
So they persuaded the legislature to an act a law requiring the passing of the bar examination by all law school graduates.
And so I tell young people, anybody who has graduated since 1951, that if you had to take the bar examination, you can, of course, blame me.
All right. The first graduate, the class of 50, did not have to take the examination. But the second class, my class, came into contact with that new requirement.
And we had to take the examination. By the way, I was the only person who passed of the group. Now, whether the examination was fairly administered or anything like that, I cannot tell you, but I can tell you I studied my can off for the thing.
And I have no question in my mind that I passed. I took an enormously long time to answer your question.
Oh, Judge, that's wonderful. Let me, let me, it's, it's superb and exactly what we're hoping to learn. So thank you, brothers. Let me, let me ask you this. So, so graduating in 51. Obviously, being in law school 48 to 51, you're, you're tracking cases like Sweatt v. Painter (1950) and McLaurin v. Oklahoma State Regents and so that, that would be those would be notes of some optimism and a still very difficult question.
Yes, I, I studied them. As every case was decided, I studied them and I sat and I, they became a part of my, my, my concepts. And whenever other cases were tried, if it was physically possible for me to do so, I went and I attended.
I began even before law school, even during law school, but certainly during my first period after I graduated from law school, I would go and I would sit in the courtroom while cases were being tried.
May I ask? Certainly. I want to ask indeed if you have any recollections of sitting on, and at the trial phase of Briggs VL. Yes, yes. By the way, Briggs v. Elliott came to trial in, what was it? And early June of 1951 and I had just graduated from law school.
Had already taken the bar examination. The results, of course, had not yet been published. I didn't know whether I had passed or failed. So I and a few others traveled to Charleston. Now there were hordes of people there. It was a well-publicized case and of course you had, this turned out it was going to be a major challenge.
It was a challenge to segregated education. And so I managed to worm through the crowd and ultimately didn't immediately succeed in getting into the courtroom. But being tall and having a long neck, I was able to rubberneck over and eventually I managed to squeeze into the courtroom.
Yes, I sat and I witnessed the trial of Briggs v. Elliott. Meanwhile, you're also having to find a strategy that will earn you a living. And it's not an easy thing.
Can you tell me this? Can you quickly sketch the nature of black law practice in South Carolina and there weren't many black lawyers, obviously, nearly 50s? And then how you made your choice about how to proceed.
Yes, there was no such thing. I couldn't get a job, certainly not of a law clerk. No government employment was offered me. In fact, no employment opportunities presented themselves.
And so it became obvious that if it was going to be the law, that I was going to have to open a law office. Well, I was born and reared in Columbia, that was home.
I had relatives in Spartanburg, one of whom operated a rather successful, funeral home establishment. And he and my mother conferred and he suggested to my mother that it would be a good idea if I chose to come to Spartanburg.
Spartanburg did not have any black attorneys. Columbia, by the way, had, I think, about three at the time. So Columbia was considered crowded. Can you imagine that?
And ultimately, of course, I went to Spartanburg. By the way, I practiced there and stayed there for 10 years before I returned in the end of the 1950s, early 1960s, to come back to Columbia.
Well, I opened a law office in the band, and it must have been a condemned building.
A one-room office desk that I had purchased from some company, a second-hand desk, had an old typewriter, Underwood and everything.
And this was, of course, before word processing, certainly before computers and everything. And by the way, I did have some typing skills. So I was able to type my own documents.
No secretary. That was later. I had a lot of the question. And of course, you know, the idea was, you needed cases. Well, you know, people just don't rush into the office of a very young inexperienced lawyer.
Certainly not a young inexperienced black lawyer. White lawyers might fare just a slight bit better, but when you're young and inexperienced, you don't attract business.
Now, this cousin of mine who had this business signed a bond in some way, got a person out of custody who had committed some traffic offense.
Just a simple traffic offense. That got to the municipal court. So this was my first foray into a courtroom. And so I went and there were lots of people, plenty of young lawyers also, of whom I was the only black.
And the municipal judge who was just a racist of the first owner received the other lawyers cordially. By the way, the extent of his authority and jurisdiction was upon the finding of guilty to impose a sentence that included either imprisonment for up to 30 days or in the court.
Or a monetary fine of up to $100. That was the extent of his authority. And so routinely, as these young white lawyers appeared before him, he was letting them off with $10 fine or maybe $15 or just probation.
And finally, when they called my case, I went forward. By the way, I had on my clean suit, my clean shirt. I had my briefcase that my wife had given me for graduation. Didn't have a thing in it, but a legal op-ed.
And I went forward, stood before him. There wasn't a prosecuting attorney. The police officers normally did their own prosecuting. So he looked up at me and said, yeah, what you want? I said, well, you're on. I'm Matthew Perry. I'm an attorney here to represent Mr. Sutton Sucks.
So he looked at the frown on his face and without affording me an opportunity to present evidence on behalf of my client, he announced that he found my client guilty and imposed a sentence of 30 days or a fine of $100.
By comparison, you see with what he had been doing. Well, I was crushed because of the unfairness of what could I do about it? You can't imagine that didn't do anything for my reputation.
Who would want to hire a young lawyer who got that kind of result at the municipal court? It took quite a while for me to get another case. And the next time I went over there, something similar happened.
And so on a third time, sometimes later, by this time I had learned, you see in law school, you don't really learn how to operate in court back at that time. Now, in today's law school trainings, much of this is imparted to students in clinical courses, but not then, certainly not in our law school.
To appeal from a decision of the municipal court, you had to file your appeal within five days.
The appeal was from the municipal court to the circuit court of the county and from an adverse decision there to the state Supreme Court.
So the circuit judges had appellate rights over the decisions of municipal courts and also magistrates courts.
But you had to serve a notice of appeal and your notice had to contain your exceptions, the grounds on which you were going to appeal.
Well, I had come upon this idea, if you're going to exist here, you've got to find a way to get around this judge.
And so I learned how to draft a notice of appeal. And so I had drafted the notice of appeal for use and when the case came, I put the name of the client on it.
And of course, very simply, I had some grounds that the decision was not based upon evidence, was contrary to the evidence presented.
Words of that sort, I forget what other ground I laid out in there, but it was a good ground.
And so when I appeared before him, he tried the same thing. And when he did, I opened my briefcase, still burned new briefcase, pulled out my notice of appeal, laid it before him.
It had to be served upon the municipal judge. He had to acknowledge receipt of it. And I said, Your Honor, would you please accept service of this notice of appeal?
So he was shocked, he looked up at me and he says, what is this? How did you know what my decision was going to be? I said, Your Honor, I said, this has been your decision every time I've come here.
No doubt my mind. So would you. So I went up to the circuit judge and I got him reversed.
Now the next time I've been, the reception was somewhat different.
And so meanwhile the word had begun to get around. People started coming to me in Spartanburg County. And the word began to spread into a joining counties.
I began getting calls. One such call came from some people down in Union County that adjoined Spartanburg County to the south.
A group down there called the Union County Voters League, a group of black citizens, gotten together to form a local group to address injustices.
And so there was a young man who had been convicted of some offense before a magistrate judge down there.
He was given just gargantuan sentence under circumstances that were unjustified. And they came to me, they didn't get to me until day number six, by the way, the five day rule was applicable.
Now I had to get around the fact that the appeal time had expired. And yet here was this young man sitting in jail. He was illiterate. His family was illiterate.
And these were people who had no resources at all. And so I decided to file a petition for a a writ of habeas corpus.
And so I had to get the job done. I had to get a job done. And so I had to get a job done. And so I had to get a job done.
So I had to get my first victory in the South Carolina Supreme Court. Certainly.
I know we have, I think about ten more minutes. I want to draw your attention to two issues.
One is the network of civil rights attorneys into which you became in the early 50s and mid 1950s closely involved.
And your perspectives on that expanding network, you've mentioned for good marshal Robert L. Carter, but now the circle will move even further. And how that I'm interested in your perspectives on that network and how it operated and what it meant to you as a yes.
I'm going to go back on. Let me have you start with that. And then I'll finish with one question. We'll talk about the funding case.
Well, of course, I became associated with with the NAACP Legal Defense Fund. In this respect, I became what was popular known as a cooperating attorney.
I was not paid employee. However, that group paid a small stipend from time to time whenever I handled a case that was supported by that group.
I also became friendly with and associated with the office of the NAACP General Counsel. Two separate organizations. And in this respect, why the public knew nothing about such a division, but it nevertheless was a fact.
And in this respect, why I attended seminars sponsored by the NAACP Legal Defense Fund and by the NAACP Office of General Counsel at all of its national conventions.
They had meetings of lawyers who were called in from around the country. And we formed a network of associates. We began to interact with each other nationally. We formed friendships and we gained a measure of knowledge about what was going on in various places.
And in this respect, why I guess we grew and we developed.
And I know one very interesting experience that arose out of that network was you traveled to D.C. for the Dryer Run.
Oh, yes. I did.
Can you describe that experience?
When the cases were set for argument in the Supreme Court, lawyers from around the country gathered as did other citizens from around the country.
And so I, on a group of South Carolina colleagues, traveled to Washington. And the cases were first argued moot court style over at the Howard University Law School.
The justices, of course, were in some instances professors at Howard or distinguished lawyers from around the country who sat and who mimicked and who acted as the then sitting Supreme Court justices.
Each of them, you know, speaking to or representing the judicial philosophy of a particular justice.
And so these lawyers argued, argued out the principle that they argued before the Supreme Court beginning the following day.
It was an exhilarating experience.
They're good martial, Robert L. Carter, Spottswood W. Robinson III.
Jack Greenberg?
Yeah, Jack Greenberg argued, yes.
You see, Constance Baker Motley, had become a part of the staff but did not argue either of the cases.
She was then sort of a neophyte.
Let me ask him to finish up here today.
Well, you became involved in a very interesting and very important case that evolved from 54 to 56, the Fleming case on Interstate travel.
And I wonder if you can describe that case in a simplification?
Well, Fleming v. South Carolina Electric and Gas Company, the bus transportation system in Columbia, South Carolina, was then, is it still operated by the South Carolina Electric and Gas Company?
At least it was then. I'll have to come up to date on who operates it now.
But the bus passenger service was provided on a segregated basis.
You got into the bus. If you were a black citizen, you went to the back of the bus and you sat on seats beginning from the back for it.
Never sitting in an area of the bus reserved for white citizens.
Again, I grew up as a boy under that system. I guess as a boy, as a child, I just accepted it. It didn't offend me.
But as I grew, as I began to grow intellectually, I did begin to wonder about it.
There was, of course, a law in South Carolina that required such racial separation, whites from the front and blacks from the rear.
So the case that you mentioned, Sarah Mae Fleming, she later became Sarah Mae Fleming Brown, a young black woman traveling to her place of employment.
As a domestic sat on a seat near the dividing line, you might say, but one that the bus driver perceived was for whites.
He ordered her to remove herself. And through some difficulty, she was trying to get off of the bus.
And even there, he was going to prohibit her leaving through the front door. Buses had a front door and another door in the back. He was going to require her to go out of the other door.
In the process, he shoved her. She claimed that he hit her in her abdomen. In any event, she came and she made her situation known to local persons.
There was a woman here at the time who became very famous, very active in South Carolina civil rights matters, Mrs. Simkins, a Modjeska Monteith Simkins.
And Mrs. Simkins sent her to a very fine white attorney named Wittenberg, Phil Wittenberg. And Mr. Wittenberg followed suit on behalf of Mrs. Fleming against the South Carolina Electric Gas Company.
He, by the way, incurred the wrath of the white community and so doing. But in the event, he did. And his case, let's see, they dismissed his case. He went out.
And so they contacted Thurgood Marshall's office. And so they came. He, Thurgood Marshall and Robert L. Carter came. And they appealed the case to the fourth circuit.
the Fourth Circuit reversed and sent it back. Well, meanwhile, I understand what the clan or somebody burned across on Mr. Wittenburg's yard over there in Sumter County.
And either then or later, he got out of the case.
I'd love to stay there. Thank you. Yes. Because family loves to stay. That's right. And so the case was sent to a friend of mine with whom I later joined and we joined forces, Lincoln Jenkins Jr, who took over her case at the trial level.
And he called me to come and assist him. I came to Columbia. I was still at Spartanburg. And we ultimately went to trial. By the way, the precedent had already been established in the fourth circuit holding that the South Carolina Statute requiring.
Separation of the races on intrastate travel in South Carolina was unconstitutional. And so we went to trial. We brought the case to trial, but we lost it at trial. The trial judged no friend of ours dealt with us.
But we left with the impression that the case had served its purpose. Now that case preceded Browder v. Gayle. The Montgomery bus case. Of course, that everybody says this was the premier case. That case made Ms. Rosa Parks famous.
But Sarah Mae Fleming Brown's case was the first one on the record.
Indeed. Her, her, her, the, the incident that set it all in motion was June 22, 1954 indeed. Yes.
Montgomery case. Right. Judge, we want to be respectful of your time. In fact, I think we've kept you a tad bit beyond even what was announced. And, and I'm responsible for it.
But I just want to say, special honor and privilege it is for us. And we're most, most grateful. And it's, it's an extra privilege to, to meet you here in this courthouse named for you.
Thank you. Thank you. And we're, we're very grateful for the opportunity. Well, I'm certainly, it's my pleasure. And I thank you for coming.
Thank you.
And it has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.